hello and welcome to this episode of the
corridor digital podcast where we sit
down with the wonderful Anna Akana and
she tells us about her life her
experiences the things she makes and why
we talk about comedy we talk about
diversity we talk about sex we talk
about sandwiches and best friends and of
course cats so please come along join us
and remember consider subscribing and
that's it we're gonna go to the episode
now see you over there Anna Akana hi how
are you doing I'm so great now that I'm
here on corridor cat good I parking is a
nightmare out there glad you made it
yeah so you're into cats right I have
five I used to have six one ran away
last year we did my favorite one of
yours is the what's his name Congress
Congress Congress yeah
do you ever just say that the worst
things to your cats no like no you don't
mine art minor minor no mine are so like
everyone who comes to my house is like
these cats are so nice so social they're
very well behaved well there's not
really well behaved but they're very
nice yeah well my so I have a cat he's
social but he's what's she but she still
is a cat though she still wants to
attack things and she's still like this
morning yeah she was running into the
bathroom just grabbing stuff out of the
garbage can oh my god and then running
out cuz I'd be like get out of here her
name's Myrtle yeah what's the street
it's a street that in my hometown yeah
and and then I went into the room and
she's scratching on the carpet and and
so I just I realized and I say the worst
things to her I'm just like I'm gonna
murder you I'm gonna skin you and use
your fur for the inside of my boot Wow
yeah you don't say stuff like now cuz I
know they're cats and I don't expect
them to behave anywhere I want this kind
of that's kind of fun to say stuff to
them no no
knowing I make them kiss me like if they
don't want to I hold their heads and I
like force myself upon them I don't like
this isn't right I feel like we can
continue from here that's okay we're on
the same page so let's let's let's start
off here with with a very broad topic
but I think it's gonna help hone in on
who you are and what you do for people
that don't know you are I think one of
the best creators out there at taking a
self-reflection on a common experience
and then doing something creative with
it and turning it into a video yeah I
mean you've sort of made your major name
on that and I think that comes from not
only but your your style but your
background and and sort of how you came
up and into the scene in LA and and in
all that stuff so I kind of wanted to
start and just you know just have you
explain where where you came from and
how you got into this whole that's
because I read your book and you know
you kind of you came up from Marietta
riot or Temecula but yes but you were
only there for a little bit you were in
them your parents were in the military
yeah my father was a Marine Corps
officer so since I mean I think by the
time I was six
I'd already lived in 13 States he was a
pretty high in demand aerospace engineer
so he'd work on jets and as you know
we're in Wars so yeah he would have to
go all over the place to just work on
jets and be a navigator right so I got
very used to being the new kid all the
time and knowing that you know you have
to attach to people quickly make
friendships quickly and then you're
gonna leave before you know it as well
so it's this weird sense where I kind of
like go all-in on something but then I'm
able to detach and let it go and move on
very quickly which i think is helps me a
lot in LA and do you find that that's
been more of a blessing in your life or
more of a curse um I think it take I
think it depends on how extreme it can
be because I it's a it's a curse because
when I moved here I didn't expect to
like always be here if that makes that
sure so you're like oh I can't just like
[ __ ] off and because I'm gonna run into
this person like in three years work
with them later
and so there's this weird aspect where
I'm like oh yeah like I have to if I
want friendships I have to learn how to
maintain them as well it's not just like
a whole over friends for two years and
then like we're kind of done scenario
it's like oh if you are meaningful in my
life then I have to like make that
effort have you been integrated into my
life
and I've never had to do that with
anyone ever so it's been a learning
experience
yeah which most people you know for me
I've one of the guys I know I've known
since I was three years old oh my god
yeah um you know it's one of those
things where you see it I see him around
and I go hey how's it going and it's
like the same you just pick up the same
conversation that we were having 10
years prior yeah but Wow okay so what
are the some of the methods from from
this background that you've that you've
taken and applied into how you write and
well I guess I would say my mom and my
dad so my life always felt bifurcated by
their two point of views my dad's all
business he's all about education
intellect very heady guy he's an
Aquarius
my mom is is a homemaker an artist so
she she loves doing like random projects
she'll like randomly pick up crocheting
or knitting or do watercolor and she's
more like free-spirited and sort of
flurry of a woman and so I feel like
being raised by both of them I had the
perfect balance between show and
business because I knew how to be
free-spirited and have fun and like
acquire new skills and be creative from
my mom but then I knew how to apply
discipline to that practice by my dad's
like rigorous schedule and work ethic
okay so I feel like those two
experiences allowed me to sort of be
creative in a way that was also
productive and prolific and approach my
work not just as like oh I'm gonna do
this whenever I feel creative but oh I'm
gonna approach this as though it's an
assignment at school yeah yeah yeah for
sure yeah and then I was reading you you
did work at first of all I heard this on
another podcast but Will Ferrell was
talking about Groundlings yeah did you
do what is that so Groundlings is like a
school like UCB or Second City where
they teach you comedy and The
Groundlings approach is all you need is
a character a very strong character with
a very specific point of view
and from there you can make anything
funny and so a lot of people who are on
SNL actually came from Groundlings
because it's all about character
different comedy right so they have a
bunch of different tears in which you do
their classes and then you test to be
like in their advanced shops where you
can then perform on their stage and you
started that right when you got here I
did all the schools so I did second city
IO UCB yeah Groundlings as well how did
you support yourself through all that
you were working to at the same time or
yeah I was a waitress of babies that are
a personal assistant at chiropractors
assistant and an underground poker
player hostess for a short time and when
so when did you when did you go to take
these classes at night yeah there's like
they're only usually like once a week so
I would just like go through the
eight-week course like either on a
weekend or on an evening and just have
that blocked off in my schedule right
yeah Wow okay okay at what point did you
did you sort of feel like your comedy
game was was starting to form and and
and what was the what was the initial
like hey there's a format here you know
when did it first hit for you that that
there was a format there that you could
turn into something well I was doing
stand-up first so I think doing stand-up
at the same time as YouTube was really
helpful in developing what my voice was
so I felt like where'd you do stand-up
all over town like laundromats coffee
places and then yeah like laundromats to
like just stand up yeah there's a random
shows like it's laundromat and people
don't want to listen to you it's awful
oh my god I want to try that it's you
don't know people are just trying to
like fold their underwear and not make
eye contact with you so like I don't I'm
not here to listen to you make jokes
[Laughter]
really bad is your testing joke some
people they're just like they just don't
care but it's good to do those places
because then if it jokes good if it
makes people like chuckle in that place
and if you go to a comedy club
it'll get like a standing ovation cuz
those are people who are ready to laugh
who have paid to laugh right
so I feel like I was able to get really
resilient really quickly in my comedy
and also find what worked and what
didn't because you're there up close
with people yeah um I forgot the
original question oh it was part of how
it was part of Groundlings and sort of
what why that helped you with creating
YouTube videos that's where I was going
oh so what this what the source of that
the format yeah the format well I also
borrowed a lot from content I liked
watching so nigahiga I loved community
channel on a piece lip and I was like oh
I love the way that people are doing
clones I love the freedom with video how
you can do cutaways to like really
illustrate something and for me one of
my strong suits in school was always
writing essays so one of my side
businesses as a student was like writing
essays for other people essentially for
good grades okay and so in that format
of doing a monologue to camera
interjected with cutaways I could
literally break it down like a thesis
paper so you would people would pay you
to write essays for ya
wet wet okay let's go back to junior
high high school like middle school he
has when I started when he started slang
and essays you need to know about
Shakespeare how many words dollar a word
I think you want a B+ you don't want a
straight-a you know you're more of a
b-minus kind of guy just sit back I got
it from here exactly
Wow okay so that probably helped a ton
because you can look at something and
break it down yeah kind of right away
and I sort of have a very specific
format of like you know the opening
section is something that's just like a
throwaway joke and then you get into
your thesis statement and then you use
the next cutaway to either illustrate
that example or oppose it for the sake
of comedy and so I got very analytical
with it
illustrations yes do you do those
yourself I know I have an animator but I
used to do freelance storyboarding okay
so you because it's I mean from what I
gather you at one point you were doing
everything from start to finish
illustrations cuts shooting sound design
yes music yeah
okay yeah now I have a crew thank God we
thank God yeah yeah yeah no cuz that
would but it's necessary
yeah in order to understand that the
totality of the form you need to you
need to have a hand in it and each in
each stage and I think it makes you a
better all-around everything like I feel
like a better actor because of a better
director but a writer because then you
have an insight into how every job works
you know how to make it more efficient
for everyone you should put that on a
business card and I cannot better ever
better all-around everything jack of all
trade there you go cool that well I
think that wraps it up I think we're
done we're done here yeah well thank you
for having me on the corner yeah like
comment subscribe okay here's a question
and I'm sure you've gotten this through
the years but do you have do you have a
mentor do you have do you have someone
in art and in comedy maybe in writing
that you've looked up to someone someone
who's yeah I've had several real life
mentors that have gone terribly south oh
of people trying to take advantage and
make me sign paperwork that would
benefit them but stripped me of rights
in a project or I had like an art mentor
who was a famous artist back in the day
he's like Spielberg's right-hand man but
it was slowly deteriorating because he
never wore one of those respirators and
back then they used a lot of toxic
chemicals so a lot of those older guys
doing art design have like literally
gone insane because of the way that the
chemicals have affected them over the
years okay can you tell me more about
that like who can we talk about these
people I don't want a lawsuit on my
hands but like I can I won't say names
but yeah I can give you situations yeah
I can tell me about this
what was he what did what was he
inhaling that made him he wouldn't like
make props and sets and aliens and yeah
he was he's a brilliant artist but he
would literally not wear any of the
safeguarded you know stuff you're
supposed to wear with these toxic
chemicals that you're handling right um
and so it's really well known in the art
community that before people knew about
this they
inhaling it for years and so now they're
kind of all a little right yeah and that
okay yeah well that's not really a
mentor though you know of you isn't a
mentor well he wasn't in the beginning
so in the beginning he was all about
like I'm here to support your dreams
like you know gave me a lot of insight
into how the business works because I
was just starting out helped me out do a
lot of self starter projects was a go-to
person for advice and then it's you know
after two years and when you really get
to know a person you're like oh wait
like you're saying everyone screwed you
over but you know if someone says
everyone else is the [ __ ] it usually
means it's you right
and just hearing other stories of other
people who are like oh no like this is
what's actually happening with that guy
or with this woman and you know you show
up to LA bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
and then very quickly realize like it's
like America shook itself and all the
crazy smell into LA that's exactly what
yeah and here it's the world shook
itself and all the crazies ended up here
yeah okay so well that's still not
that's not really a mentor well he was
at the time he was someone who I really
looked up to who was I thought so
talented and gave me a lot of practical
advice that I could use in the industry
so you know our relationship ended in a
really negative way but that wasn't till
like two years down the road okay yeah
because that's something the reason why
I asked that question is because you
know you've done a lot of things that
have made you self self-made
you know in a way and you know we like
to think that around here as well and
the thing about it the thing that I've
found difficult is we've we haven't I
feel like there hasn't been a mentor and
in the space that we're in there's not
people have been doing it for 30 years
we can go let me tell you how this works
kid because it's just different now I
think were the mentors now yeah that's
probably true I mean
that because you started in 2011-2012
when did you post your first video 2010
2010 yeah okay and then you just kind of
tinkered from there and and then what
point did you feel like you were hitting
your stride on a new format yeah
probably like 2015 2014 2015 is when I
was like okay I got this down but then
you know you come across the hurdle of
I've said every opinion I have about
every topic I can think of what do I do
now
yeah so what do you do at that point you
write a video about having no more ideas
and that gives you more ideas yeah and
then you just try to go out and like I
had a period where I would just say yes
to things I didn't want to do because I
was like I need stories to tell I need
content right and so I got into this
very bad habit of being like this looks
like a bad situation but I'm gonna do it
anyway cuz I need a good story yeah yeah
and did that yield the results you were
yeah okay lots of content I mean yeah I
see you kind of looking more at your
style I feel like you kind of have a
comedian style to to you're at least to
the way that you dig for stories and the
way that you dig for things I mean
that's seems common you go out and you
you do different experiences to try to
see see what life throws at you yeah and
I think a lot of that comes through when
did you sort of go down your path of I'm
going to I'm going to become an artist
mm I think when I was known well I
started stand-up when I was 19 I wanted
to get an entertainment when I was five
cuz I did the Little Red Hen hand puppet
play and I was the little redhead and I
was like I was born for this like I'm
gonna be an actor
yeah even though it's like no that's
been true loquiz I'm you idiot but my
parents when I told them they were like
yeah yeah sure whatever like that's not
a real thing yeah I mean as I got older
like you know all I saw was like maybe
Lucy Liu Bruce Lee Jackie Chan and I was
like well everyone knows martial arts
and I'm kind of like clumsy I don't
think I can do it but it was when my
sister died and I saw Margaret Cho
perform stand-up was when I was like
actually yes I love this I'm
to go after this cuz I you know I'm
gonna die someday there's no point what
about her
her performance her style well it was
two years since my sister had died and
it was the first time I ever laughed for
real like and the first time I ever
forgot my sister was dead for like 20
minutes thirty minutes however long she
was on and I was like that is such a
beautiful gift to give to someone like
this kind of escape from your own tragic
reality and the ability to just like
laugh again and I was so inspired by
that and wanting to give that to someone
else that it like drove me for the next
ten years right so let's go down that
road for a second what a lot of people
probably don't know this what happened
to your sister
so she was 13 and she killed herself you
know she was younger I was 17 she was 13
okay and she was I think she struggled
with some kind of mental disorder but it
but she could have also just been a 13
year old girl going through a hard time
you know and she was being bullied at
school a bunch of boys threatened to
beat her up and this is before bullying
was never taken seriously so when she
told her counselors and her teachers
they were like they're just kidding so
she brought a airsoft gun to school to
protect herself and she's the one who
got expelled for it and so integrating
into a new school was also really hard
for her
we were very used to being an Asian
dominant countries at that point like
we'd grown up mostly either in Asia in
Hawaii where white people were actually
bullied so coming to California
Temecula is especially racist it was
such like a jarring culture shock one or
my first day like this guy was like hey
go back to China and I was like oh I'm
Japanese Filipino Hawaii and I'm not
from China sir and then he like spit on
the ground and walk away and I was like
what is up with that guy like slowly
realize like oh people here are like
racist I've never encountered this
before
yeah so she dealt with a lot of that
especially in coming from Hawaii we
spoke pidgin which sounds very
uneducated it's a very like weird slang
kind of kind of have compared to Kali
and she just yeah she had this terrible
terrible time at the new school sort of
got into a fight with like everyone in
my family and killed herself and so yeah
it was like when I realize like oh I
don't want to go into the military at
all
like I don't want to be a doctor I don't
want to be a vet like I'm gonna die
someday I should do what I actually want
to do and that's going to Entertainment
and tell stories right how long you guys
in Hawaii and before that Philippines uh
we were in Hawaii for four years and
before that we were in Japan for three
okay
yeah dad Japanese your mom my dad
Stephanie yeah he was born there okay
and then okay and then so when did he
come over here he actually came here
when he was like four or five so he came
here relatively early his father was in
the military was Hawaiian okay ma'am
yeah that's um I I didn't know how to
bring this up necessarily but I feel
like a lot of people who draw towards
comedy they have they have something in
their background that that is usually
like you know something tragic or
something difficult and they take it and
they and I think that is ultimately the
gift that it brings to the world is that
it brings people the it brings people
after and the ability to take something
tough and and to make make something not
light but to make something that makes
you feel better about it yeah but the
stand I mean it's part of the reason why
I quit though is everyone in stand-up is
so miserable really so like so so
miserable and it's also a very bitter
community compared to like the YouTube
community of the acting community like
they feel very entitled and like upset
if anyone else succeeds there's like a
real competitiveness which is very weird
because we're all doing our own acts
it's there's not enough laughter for
everyone yeah exactly and so part of the
reason why I quit was I was just like
this is a really unhealthy environment
at least the people that I was around
I've heard there are better environments
but a lot of people I came up with were
very unpleasant and suicidal or had
really crazy backstories the point where
is like dude you're like 36 get over
your dad's suicide that happened when
you were five like like it's time to
like you know turn that into something
that serves you yeah and so I mean bless
them they're like trying to use that
experience to create art that makes
other people happy but it can be a
really negative admire
yeah it's not it's definitely shouldn't
be a crutch you know at a certain point
you gotta you can't be well I'm in
comedy because I had these things happen
to me and that's why I that I'm entitled
to it yeah you got a you got to move
forward
yeah so on that note when you moved into
YouTube you you started to hit your
stride on the format of your well the
videos that work for you and how long
did it take from the first video that
you made to Wow
probably like 200 videos 200 videos you
made 200 videos before you felt like I
did like a sketch show I did vlogs I did
I was like you know playing around like
what do I like what
you know what's being until I found like
really like oh this video this format
this resonates okay what are some of the
failures that you went through before
you got to that I mean you know like a
lot of this [ __ ] on YouTube you so I was
like Here I am at the grocery store so
like just oh geez yeah guys I'm gonna
get some wasabi peas and yeah yeah I
really like this brand organic right any
other other than vlogs I mean I did like
this sketch show called ten-second
traumas with another girl from acting
class where we just made 10 second
sketches and they were drama like FML
inspired like my life site that was like
really big we're like yeah we should do
like the video versions of that right
cool right yeah about one time was that
god I didn't know I was like 20 20 20 10
yeah I was like one of the first things
I did when I moved out here yeah and
then okay and then I think well I'll get
to that but what was your first sort of
viral video or your first big one that
sort of took your channel to well the
first one I about got big was actually
one of the first ideas I ever had and I
never did excels like I hate this this
is stupid don't like this and one day I
was like I don't have anything else I
need to make my deadline so I'll just do
this stupid video that's like a parody
of a beauty
like vlog but instead of sitting on my
eyeshadow I'm gonna put on kindness so
the whole videos like life and me don't
forget like speak kind words or whatever
and it's very like cheesy but like I'm a
very cheesy person
sounds like fine like I'll just and it
got picked up by upworthy it like went
viral on reddit
like women were sending it to their
daughters because they like yeah it's
like this beautiful juxtaposition of
inner beauty and outer beauty and how
emphasis is put on outer getting I was
like okay yeah sure yeah so that was
like my first big one that like launched
me into more subscribers than I never
had before sure yeah
yeah it's usually something like that
that something that's off-the-cuff
something that oh yeah the thing you
like work the hardest son no one cares
oh yeah all the time but in a way that I
think that Foster's the ones you don't
care as much about and those you pull on
those things you know you go through the
big one and you're like okay I feel like
having a new creative Plateau yeah and
and all this in that thing doesn't work
but all the stuff it took to get there
mm-hmm
fosters this sort of new new new ground
I think yeah that's a good mentality
about it it keeps me moving forward
anyway yeah yeah you can't be negative
about it okay well this is a little bit
more of a serious topic but I think we
should dive into this because it's it
comes through in your videos and first I
want to talk a little bit about about
sex and then secondarily about you know
being a woman of color and I think is
your is is your most viewed video the
one you just put out like last year
about things I wish I did before things
I wish I knew before I had sex no that's
my second high as my first highest is
like a Google Chromebook one but I think
that's cuz I pushed it and pushed it
okay but yeah my highest videos are sex
related okay so you know as a as a
straight man who doesn't have to deal
with those
sort of issues like what would you what
do you have to say about that
you know like take this contact concept
and sort of drive at home a little bit
further like why is it that the mote
your most viewed video has to do with
sex like what because there's not a lot
of information or education for women
about it out there at least growing up I
didn't know anything about it the most
my mom told me it was like if you have
sex I'll break your legs you know like I
didn't I didn't know I like what a
vagina was till I was like 13 I had a
whole stand-up bit about like
accidentally discovering my vagina and
being like what did what is that and it
bursts in there I thought there was like
a hole in my body and I was like going
to tell my parents until I realize like
oh that's that's the vagina really not
the thing you pee out of like it's a
separate thing right and like sexual
education I don't know like what it is
across the nation but at least for me
what in the few schools that I went to
that taught it there was nothing at all
about female anatomy it was you learned
mostly about male anatomy so I knew like
all like okay yeah like those are the
guy glands and this is how that happens
and blah blah blah but like I didn't
even know most women can't come from
like can't come from penetration you
need some kind of clitoral stimulation
after like the longest time I was like
oh I'm I'm weird like I can't I can't I
just can't
I'm broken what's wrong with me yeah and
so it was really interesting to know
that never was formally no hot never
formally taught and never communicated I
had to read a sex book specifically to
in order to find out more about my own
body then like classes taught me what my
parents taught me Wow
yeah okay yeah that that explains I mean
cuz that's thinking back about it I
never thought about this but thinking
back about it that's that's all we
learned was we watched like how
basically how guys ejaculate yeah how
that leads to pregnancy
yeah and that was it that was how we
learned and I think with guys because
you guys have like an actual physical
thing that does stuff exactly more we
don't even know it
yeah but there's more education on it or
at least there's more like
experimentation with it like and it's I
think it's also more encouraged like
with guys if a guy's horny like yeah
it's a guy but a girl you're like oh my
god like yeah keep it contained like
classy yeah be a lady
yeah right yeah that okay yeah cuz you
know we here at corridor you know it's
like it's a bunch of dudes yeah and I
think it's healthy to bring that out and
you know that's been kind of one of your
messages throughout a lot of your work
is to bring out other perspectives and
other other things so just to hop
further down that rabbit hole I mean one
day one of your videos you just put out
recently is you you announcing that
you're bisexual
okay and and what
when did you just come to grips with
that I guess and only recently okay yeah
I've had a lot of internalized
homophobia for a long time that I didn't
even know was there
okay um so I've liked girls my entire
life but I definitely like men to more
oh yay yeah we have that in common
but I always thought it was just like Oh
cuz girls are pretty so like obviously
like them like they're [ __ ] beautiful
goddesses like who doesn't like women
right um and I always like I just it
took me a long time to really even like
on the label is by because it felt like
because I knew I wanted to end up with a
man and because I knew I liked men more
I felt like I couldn't claim bisexuality
and I felt like I couldn't be
romantically involved as a woman because
that was that felt like it was like
leading her on if I knew I wanted to
have a family with a man right and
that's how you currently feel is still
okay yeah but I still am very attracted
to women I still had like a lot of
sexual fantasies about women growing up
so it is like a weird thing because
bisexuality is like also just such a
spectrum like some women are mostly with
women like 9 out of 10 but still claim
bisexuality because on the odd occasion
they're attracted to a man oh like when
I was explained to me that way I was
like that's okay I feel like I can claim
that label now like that makes a lot of
sense to me yeah and here's another
label
queer yeah okay so what is it what does
that mean to be queer as it is where is
the umbrella term for the all the
letters lgbtq+ so it's just the plus
can't they just go with plus so they
want to add a now for asexuals like can
we just have like another term so I
think queer kind of became the umbrella
for all of that that's easier yeah it's
easier for everyone yeah it used to be a
derogatory slur but we've taken it back
they've you know that's the best way to
deal with it yeah you just grab ahold of
it and you're like no this is ours now
yeah this is a positive thing yeah okay
so that's just the blanket the blanket
term okay well I'm learning see
everyone's learning we're all learning
yeah we definitely all are learning on
that note when you get into moments of
self reflection from what you derive
your creativity yes
who or what are the methods that you
fall back on to sort of ground yourself
and center yourself and I guess
fact-check
if you can if you can call it that your
ideas you know I have an idea I think
it's gonna work is this too far off to
the side of the road you know how do you
how do you balance yourself out I all
this are usually I just follow my
intuition so my gut feeling always tells
me what's the right project to work on
like sometimes I'll be going really hard
on like I don't know a poetry book or
something and then I'll be like no
actually you need to do a stop motion
short now and I'm like oh okay hard left
yeah hard limits I'm like this is going
on the back burner my intuition says go
here and it's it's never really led me
astray like I think I was talking to
like Mike and Nico about this once but I
remember I saw dubstep guns my brother
like randomly showed me dubstep guns and
I was like oh those are gonna be my
friends someday and he was like haha
yeah okay whatever I was like no for
real I think like that one guy's gonna
be like my best friend
and and like I met Mike years later at a
party and we were like best friends now
right
and so I've always had these weird
moments in my life where like a little
voice inside of me
tell me something and I've been like
okay like I'll trust this voice because
it's never led me astray and so for
creativity and for staying grounded and
balanced I just really try to get quiet
and listen and sometimes it's like stop
working like you need to take a week to
just like chill the [ __ ] out
or sometimes it tells me to start a
completely new endeavor and I'm like
really aren't I doing enough already do
I really have just like tackle this
album but yeah I'm very much led by
whatever it is that voice is you did an
album I did Wow yeah what is it called
casualty casualty by Anna Akana mm-hmm
what's the what's your favorite song on
it I think maybe the first song on it
it's also my lead single it's called
intervention because I've had like
alcohol abuse problems my entire life
and I've never really confronted them
until it like made me lose a really
valuable relationship and but the song
itself is about like I don't need to go
to AAA I don't need an intervention I
can handle this on my own yeah and is
that something you eventually had to do
or did you handle it on your own no I've
been handling on my own I've been sober
now I've had bouts of sobriety I'm sober
for four days look at me no but I did I
do little bouts of sobriety here in
there and then any time I feel myself
like I don't imagine being sober for the
rest of my life that sounds [ __ ]
miserable yeah but when I feel myself
you know abusing a substance to avoid my
own feelings is when I'm like okay like
quit stop that like a doughnut you're
shown and yeah yeah yeah I'm kind of the
same way with respect to that I couldn't
imagine not having a beer for the rest
of my life but you definitely want to
keep a sharp eye on that stuff cuz it'll
sneak up on you oh so easy it sneaks up
on a lot of people and and you don't
even notice it no it's so easy to fall
into it yeah like sometimes I'm like
yeah of course I have a drink or two or
three by myself at home every day yeah
yeah yep where were we going with that
creativity processes right yeah I also
journal yourself journal a lot to myself
I love journaling got something you've
done your whole life whole life I have
so many journals really yeah just axis -
secret secret rooms
my parents have a lot of them actually a
lot of my old school ones yeah I used to
keep I used to write like lyrics and I
used to keep them in in notebooks do you
still have them I've got some of them I
don't think I don't think my wife even
knows I have him I like hide in my
library because I'm embarrassed she
reads them she's right yeah but they're
so old you know they're like I wrote
them when I was literally half my age
the problem is they're just earnest and
pure yeah or just amateur and bad maybe
I don't know I think sometimes I look
back on the stuff I wrote when I was
really young and I'm like this is quite
good for a 19 year old or what up job
good job little me go back in time show
up good good work keep going keep going
with this run go with this one yeah yeah
I'm sure that helps too you know just
that just the hours and hours of of
writing yeah that eventually you see
that spark and in inside of something
you've written oh there's an idea here
100% and I've also found my music is
often more honest than I can be with
myself I'll write a lot of things in
music that I'm like I don't feel this
way or this is not gonna happen and then
like later I'm like no of course I won't
you [ __ ] idiot yeah your song yeah
about life yeah realize later it's about
you yeah yeah yep definitely cool that I
think that that that takes us to the
point where I want to go back a little
bit yeah and I want to and I want to
have you explain a little bit more
because we just hit a lot of topics yeah
but throughout all the times where you
were moving yeah is there who was your
best friend was it yourself was was it
your sister I mean I had a new best
friend wherever I was I would like find
a person and I'd be like I'm your friend
and like glom onto them okay yeah seems
like clingy yeah it was very clingy for
like two three years yeah and then they
and then I would leave and never write
back Hiromi letters it's awful really
yeah Wow
so what at what point did you feel like
hey maybe I shouldn't do this anymore
when I was in LA and I started realizing
like every two or three years I would
have a huge falling out with a friend
group and I went into therapy and I was
like why does this keep happening and
it's like well it's literally been your
entire life is you
you know something gets destroyed and
you start over so now you have to learn
how to maintain stuff yeah so do you
have a best friend now I do her name is
Gabby Gabby yeah Gabby gab yeah she's
from high school and then I also have a
best friend here from LA named Kat whose
makeup artist oh yeah I know Kat yeah
yeah she's great she's awesome
what do you guys do for fun we do body
paints okay we create Instagram content
for fun so we feel like we're working
okay we just get to hang out for three
hours and eat food like excuse right off
- hang out yeah exactly
okay what do you summary what are you
some of your favorite photos you've done
with her oh man she painted a suit on my
body once and it looked so real really
yeah it looked like it people were using
tide yes yeah people were like where'd
you get that suit that fits you really
good I was like that's paint man Thanks
no okay what about with Gabby what do
you guys do Gabby's actually food she's
in food PR so she like geeked out over
Jonathan gold when she met him he's like
a huge food critic who recently passed
away and so she'll actually because I'm
a quote unquote influencer invite me to
be at restaurants for their events I get
to eat all their stuff yes recently we
did a show we went to Jewel and I got to
eat everything on their menu and just do
reactions for camera and it was great
yeah umami undertow what what kind of
food was there they have amazing a lot
of gluten-free vegan but like like weird
stuff I can't even explain it it's just
good okay yeah they have a lot of good
food there good food there yeah so food
is something you've sort of had your ups
and downs with throughout your life
I wake up in the morning but I also used
to be like a really chronic binge eater
and it took me a long time to deal with
back so I was like well I'm skinny so
like it doesn't matter if like I eat so
I like clearly I'm fine I'm fine
you know I'm having all these digestive
problems i'm afaid and i also took a
weird pride and being able to eat a lot
because people are always like wow she
ate that whole subway stinking rich
petite girl eating all the food yeah
right and so it was a problem for like
four or five years where I was like I'm
having chronic like stomach pain and
like is that how you met Gabby was
through food oh yeah was it we went in
high school and we both loved food like
insanely and then would you dip out of
school and let go across the street to
get different food than what was offered
sometimes yeah yeah subway and we both
get footlongs and like race each other
to see who could eat it yeah it was
stupid how fast we the winner usually
yeah I could I was definitely the winner
excited you I was used to having to eat
fast cuz of ROTC you have like 15
minutes to inhale your food yeah and I
just love consuming like some something
about like filling that void inside of
you with food was so like my jam right
yeah what would you do in ROTC what was
your I was so I basically thought I was
gonna go into the military my whole life
so I do military camps every summer so I
do like kept like capture the flag or
like various things and I took it way
too seriously like I would piss my pants
in the middle of capture the flag game
cuz like I'm gonna win and I'm not gonna
stop to the bathroom just gonna run and
piss my pants
legit legit like I loved that [ __ ] so
much dedication
you know it's gross but like yeah at the
time I was like I'm gonna write yeah do
you think okay just to harp into a Dan
Carlin podcast here have you ever
listened to him okay well he does these
hardcore history podcasts where he goes
into like different histories of the
world and he has this one on the
Japanese Empire and about how hero
Emoto I believe his name was how he
didn't believe that World War two was
over until 1974 he was living on an
island in the Philippines yeah and he
still fighting the war because he he
wasn't he wasn't to be relieved from his
post until his squad commander relieved
him personally yeah
so they sent him all this information
and they tried to tell him and
eventually they had to pull his sergeant
to the island as an old man to
officially relieve him of his duties to
the Empire Wow yeah do you feel like
that level of like dedication like I'm
gonna piss my pants for this do you
think any of that has to do with having
a Japanese background probably actually
the Japanese are very stubborn my dad's
very stubborn he like will never admit
he's wrong even if I'm like holding a
piece of paper with all the facts I know
that sound effects certify yes amped
yeah there's like a sense of like honor
but it's not honor you're like just
hiding your shame right yeah huh crazy
yeah yeah I'm too white to understand
that I just Midwest boy right here yeah
yeah good - yeah we got some good things
going on we got clean air we got fresh
air there's a lot of honesty kindness
like good values in the Midwest I spent
a lot of time in the Midwest yeah I
liked it a lot
we're about um I was in Virginia North
Carolina South Dakota okay yeah
Virginians Virginia is the east
I don't really know it's all like Oh
anything not LA or New York is
Midwestern okay everything in between
yeah right yeah South Dakota there's not
much there but definitely Missouri - I
like Missouri okay yeah yeah Wisconsin's
nice yeah Wisconsin it's God's country
yeah what's not to love man a lot yeah
yeah cornfields the Packers chicken they
got that they got some of that it's more
in Missouri though yeah yeah yeah we're
down about that down about those ways
yeah okay so you and Gabby high school
you guys are eating sandwiches and then
when you meet Cat Cat I actually met
snapper here Oh so like the very first
time I ever worked with you guys a
snapper here snapchats first scripted
series yeah and her she was dating Jan
at the time our DP yep and I met her at
the wrap party for a snapper here oh
yeah yeah and we just became friends
and then what was the first time she
painted your naked body yeah how many
remember she's done it so many times at
this point we didn't take a moment to
get there with somebody or do you just
like hey come over on Friday we're doing
Fried Chicken and naked no no when she
did it so I was dating someone and you
know those t-shirts those oversized
t-shirts with like women's bodies
painted on them in a bikini yeah
so I the guy I was dating was like this
is the first thing I ever masturbated to
cuz he had no access to poker yeah okay
and so I was like the female form yes on
a t-shirt right and he would hide it so
his parents couldn't find it as a cat
can you paint this t-shirt on my body
and make it look like I'm wearing this
t-shirt and she said yeah totally and so
I sent him the photo of the t-shirts
like this is the first thing you ever
masturbated to and I sent him a photo of
me as the t-shirt and I was like this
will be the last and we loved it so much
we just started doing more body paints
after that for fun okay yeah that's cool
yeah I've seen a few of them they're
pretty great yeah she's very talented so
talented and I love getting just stand
there for three hours and talk to a
friend and then just take a photo yeah
it's like yeah we were creative yeah
hell yeah
yeah and post it yeah yeah the detail
that she has the layering in the paint
what does she use um it really depends
on whatever the paint job is okay yeah
okay but usually whatever does she do
airbrushing sometimes mostly though by
hand oh wow yeah have you ever had to do
that for any of your acting gigs like do
really intense makeup no I've done
prosthetics once as like I went ahead to
be like an old woman but usually not
usually if I write things with aliens
I'm the one human and they all have to
sit in the chair for four hours [ __ ]
aliens right yeah you guys are gonna be
aliens yeah you're aliens and I'm the
most beautiful woman in the world known
as Miss Earth that's right yeah yes miss
20:59 yeah how many seasons did you guys
do we did two and then go 90 went under
but we were in talks to do a season
three and then they were like actually
we're bankrupt by and did you were you
they did you get creative created by
credit on that and
okay so everything from characters
writing to yeah did you have final edit
- um no new form had final edit okay
yeah but you were the author so does
basically yeah I created the
proof-of-concept with that mentor who
went horribly awry and then sold it to
go 9d and then developed it with some
show show runners okay yeah what did
that start from storyboards like of your
own storyboards um how did I think I
started missed 2015 I was really
frustrated that like I would get
conflicting auditions so one would be
like the most beautiful girl in school
and then the next day I'd be like plain
not pretty not even close to pretty just
like super plain and ugly and both of
those like I would go in for both of
them so I was like I don't understand
who I am right and so I was like you
know what I just I'm gonna make a thing
where I get to be the most beautiful
woman in the world in the future and
like I have a twin coz I've always
wanted to be a twin and I like alien so
we'll throw some aliens in there put
them in there they don't have souls they
can be your friend you can matter it
doesn't matter I wanted one to be my
boyfriend and have like a weird sex
scene and so I was just like yeah it was
really born for me just being like these
are all the things I like how can I make
them be a story cool yeah who picked
that up originally new form new form
yeah okay yeah we did a whole first
season yeah yeah awesome and then were
you able to leverage that when you when
you moved things over to you think
consequences yeah so I've had I think
like four shows so far that I've like
either written and starred in or
produced and starred in as like a sauce
tartar and name all of them as fast as
you can ready oh my god go Riley rewind
miss 20:59 searchbar you
you know there's one where but I don't
remember what it is I don't remember
okay I'd have to look at my resume okay
look at your IMDB yeah I'd have to look
at my IMDB yeah yeah cuz Riley rewind I
mean that was kind of your first one yep
yeah yeah where was that on YouTube that
was premiered on Facebook actually what
yeah I premiered on Facebook 25 million
views Facebook how long ago but like
it's like way long ago like 2012 it was
I think those Facebook's first scripted
premiere that's like the first video
ever on Facebook you did it
I know we've we've done a lot of like
first though like snapchat one of the
first yeah Instagram also doing scripted
shows now right to bread yeah so Riley
rerun on Facebook yeah 2012 yeah
then miss 2059 new form go 90 yeah that
was what 2014-15 I think so yeah and
then using consequences last year yeah
or was it this year last year no this
year March yeah yeah I I really liked
the first episode I I didn't get a
chance to get to the second episode cuz
well you know I was went to bed and this
is now I was it for me it took a moment
to warm up because I'm not into the like
high school sort of like drama calm
drama drama D sort of bits but by the
end of the first episode I was hooked I
needed to know what happened and and
that was cool I I didn't expect that
I'll be honest but that's that's where
it left me and I think I'm gonna watch
the second episode out of here
so you didn't you weren't labeled as the
creator of that one correct that so how
did you get looped into that one my
manager actually sent me the script and
was like I think you'd really like this
because I am such like a free form CW
[ __ ] I love watching teen drama shows
that are like way high end but what I
loved about Jason script and his world
was that the characters were really
smart and I'm a very avid reader so
often if I'm reading a book or a script
I can kind of see what's going and I'm
like yeah
an idea of what this is and like I'm
usually right and with his skirt I
didn't see the twists coming at all and
so I love stuff like that that really
surprises you and I loved the idea of
like getting to play like the mean
popular girl who actually has really
good intentions and an agenda but it
serves her more to sort of be a
quote-unquote [ __ ] in order to maintain
power and sort of distribute justice how
she sees fit and I always knew like with
a script like that if I was just
auditioning I would never get it they
wouldn't be like yeah let's put like
this nice-looking asian girl in this
role you know name me anybody ik even as
I read it like part of me kept being
like oh I'm imagining like a blonde
blue-eyed like I see Margaret Robbie
type and I'm like no like why can't it
be you um and so I fell in love with the
script and I met Jason and we got along
so well and I was like I have to make
this show with you
um so initially it was that freeform
with maker but maker [ __ ] it up and
then we ended up going to YouTube red
with it and they bought it cool and do
you feel like that's opened any more
doors for you or you still kind of on
the tail end of that project and seeking
your next one I'm still sort of I mean
I'm in development on another show
already so we'll see where it goes but
this one would be more for traditional
TV so now that I've had like four or
five like solid shows in digital yeah
now we can like leverage more with me in
the film TV space as like an actual
creator versus just like I've tested for
a bunch of pilots or I've been in film
and TV as a hired actor but yeah I want
to take more of the role of being behind
the scenes and having a creative say so
now I'm working on a show actually based
on my book okay yeah how far along is
that we are gonna pitch to Warner
Brothers pretty soon I have like
producers attached and we're revising
our pitch and like getting it to where
it needs to be yeah yeah do you have a
title for it yeah it's called so much
which is like you know the books called
so much you want to tell you so we're
calling it so much okay yeah cool yeah
that's um one of my friends came by the
other day and and this is kind of what
you were talking about with who you were
imagining for the lead of youth and
consequences and you know he's in
marketing and we were talking about how
I think a lot of people have
still a bit of a stigma towards who
should be in what role you know yeah and
what type of person should be in which
role and what type of cast and what type
of race and all those things yeah and
the thing that made it click for me
maybe you feel the same way about this
is he he said you know imagine you're
growing up and you are looking for
people in in pop culture that you can
draw inspiration from if you find
somebody that looks or thinks or or acts
like you do you're gonna be naturally
drawn towards that person yeah and so
it's important that you have diversity
in in casting and in projects because it
establishes that for people and for the
younger generation do you do you feel
that that's true or do you feel you know
having gaunt and growing up with that
and in your backgrounds like do you feel
differently about that I think it's a
really interesting argument and one that
I've had a lot with friends in
particular because I owe my entire
career to sing Margaret Cho perform so
for me the answer is no question
diversity is important and also they've
done studies that like what you consume
when you're growing up entertainment
wise influences your career decisions
your hobbies whether or not you get
married the Fred group you choose is it
literally forms our beliefs and so I do
think it's really important to showcase
different perspectives because we have
all these stereotypical ideas in our
head about things that we've literally
only gotten from entertainment which
showcases one lens you know I've had
also weird arguments worth like I wasn't
allowed to audition for Mulan because
I'm not Chinese and I thought that was
really I thought that was racist I was
like that's not like you're gonna
further marginalize an Asian group but I
had a friend who was Korean who fully
supported the decision I was like no we
should give the Chinese actors like
chinese-american actors the chance to go
for this and I was like but that's so
little like of what we're only five
percent of the population in terms of
Asians in America and I are going to
like make it this this small and so I
it's it's been a really interesting
conversation between people what
who made the decision on that Disney I
think so I think they were worried about
because it racism in like racial casting
and and how accurately you portray it
has been like a huge question that
people are like how do we deal with this
so sometimes what they do like for a lot
and one of my friends wasn't allowed to
go cuz I think he I don't remember what
the exact things were but they were like
oh he's the wrong kind of Middle Eastern
weeds not that Middle Eastern he's like
if I can go in the room and you can tell
me exactly what kind of Middle Eastern I
am sure I don't have me audition for
Aladdin but you don't know and so it's
been like a really weird thing now
dealing in the in our communities where
they're even further restricting which
is also annoying so I'm like how many
Japanese stories are there everyone's
either Korean or Chinese like there's
not as many Japanese people out here you
guys but I do think diversity is
important I do want to see other other
you know perspectives cuz I get bored
like I wanna one of my friends is in a
wheelchair and she's a VFX artist and
she told me this amazing story about how
when she was a teen and she wanted to
sneak out of the house her boyfriend
would have to climb the roof carry her
down go back up get her wheelchair on
his back and carry that down and then
sneak away for the night and then do it
all again when he like dropped her off
and I was like Jason it at 4:00 in the
morning like pipes and I was like that's
a story I want to [ __ ] see you know I
want to see someone with cerebral palsy
I want to see someone dealing with the
disability I want to see someone who's
just not me in a different culture like
I think I find that stuff super
inspiring because you're just feeding
yourself all these different stories
that you don't get to see on a regular
basis so as a reader I feel like I get
that a lot but in watching entertainment
it's so much more of a novelty yeah I
think that I didn't expect that people
would people would go down the road of
saying you're not you're not the right
type of Asian and you're not the right
type of Middle Eastern yeah that puts
you in a tough spot I think for her
trying to book different roles like that
and I I think they should go back and
maybe take a second look at that type of
casting because
I mean this the one thing that should be
first and foremost is does this person
portray their role mm-hmm
whether I mean regardless unless it's a
you know a historical piece I guess
Mulan technically is a historical but
it's you know it's fictional yeah but
first and foremost I mean that was what
I was listening to one of these really
old stand-ups by Donald Glover and he
was talking about how when he was being
considered for spider-man for one of the
spider-man movies there was this whole
thing about that and first and foremost
if the person can portray the role right
especially in like a fictional
environment then start there you know
that seems logical but I agree I think
so too I think it should be the best
person for the role but then I think
it's also hard because as you mentioned
think we're drawn naturally to people
who look sound like us have the same
experiences viewpoints beliefs yeah and
so if everyone who is making those
decisions are the same background then
they're gonna choose someone of the same
background and most of the time right
and that's something I encountered a lot
in the improv scene yeah and in the
comedy scene it was like a lot of the
people making these decisions were
coming from one point of view and so
obviously they found other people who
are like them much funnier than everyone
else and so would move those people up
the ranks at these schools
well yeah it's interesting cuz I like I
also don't have a problem with like oh
if you're just like bringing me onto a
projects you need to like check your
little diversity box sure if that's
gonna give me more power to then get
into a position where I can hire other
people like me or from my background
then I'll take it right because I know
some friends were like well I'm not
gonna do it if they just want me because
I'm black and I'm like no take it we eat
it like Oh get all the power you can so
you can make change right yeah I think
that's yeah you like that sort of
business oriented mindset came through I
think a bit in your book too you know
like you were talking about the poker
games that I used to serve at in you or
you were I think you said you only did
it a couple of times but these guys
would would sit you down and they'd be
like let's see how this little little
girl can play poker yeah and yeah
taking that opportunity because it gives
you to the next stage yeah the next
place of what you need to be 100 that's
cool
given the way that YouTube and digital
media has changed since we got onto the
platform when we when we started and
when you started it was TV and movies
was there was the whole thing it was the
whole the whole shebang do you feel that
that's still true do you feel that then
the world has changed a little bit and
people are kind of I guess not having
the same sort of not putting TV and film
in such a prestigious position and
looking more to what what the overall
content is adding and it doesn't really
matter where it is or do you feel like
you still have a place you want to end
up or a platform you want to end up and
if so where where would that be that's a
good question
and what I think everyone is sort of
contemplating ah yeah well that's why
I'm asking yeah I do think I saw this
commercial which I thought exemplified
it really well so there's this kid and
he like looks at a flat-screen TV and
he's like TV and then he goes in the car
and an iPad comes neck comes down he's
like TV and then his father hands him
his phone and he's a TV and so I do
think the lines are so blurry now
because do we consider a Netflix TV or
digital you know yeah and when it's the
biggest power player right now Amazon
Prime is a big power player right now
that's not friggin TV the film industry
has taken a huge hit and so for me I
think it's not necessarily the like the
prestigious nests but like the budgets
so digital very much I feel like comes
from a mindset where all the people are
like oh well you used to do this alone
in your bedroom so I can give you like
no money and you can make something
amazing right I'm sure you guys are
familiar with that all the time
especially in the VFX world yeah you're
intimately familiar with whereas I think
you know TV and film they have so much
money to play with and of course like
they still have to stick within their
budget but compared to what we're used
to you were like oh my god if I could
play with that
kind of budget who knows what I could
freaking do because you know I've had to
make sci-fi shows on a million dollars
whereas like if I were doing an actual
TV pilot I might have five and so for me
it's more about like I want to I want to
play in spaces where there's money so I
can pay people well I'm tired of paying
people like the bare minimum of what I
can [ __ ] pay them I want to feed
people well I want everyone to feel like
you know we're not having to pack
everything into a 16-hour day because we
don't have enough money to make the
seven days shoe instead of a five day
shoot you feel like though there's a
disproportion between the economy of
traditional TV in the in the true
economy of like ad dollars online you
know because I feel like that it's it
might be overvalued 100 percent I mean
we get more I used to get the same views
as every episode of girls right at the
same time yeah yeah and it was like
people were like hounding me like on my
rate and I was like are you kidding like
you pay hundreds of thousands of dollars
to be on TV for the same amount of views
but also you have me a personality who
people are invested in selling a product
that I use for you right and so it is
frustrating it's it's it's requiring a
lot of education of advertisers and
executives who don't quite get it and
don't understand the value of what you
do yeah that's definitely true I'm
definitely seeing that and I think it's
probably gonna land to realistically
somewhere in the middle mm-hmm you know
over the next five years five five to
ten years we'll continue to see it
evolve yeah but I think you're right TV
and reference that commercial it's kind
of everywhere and there's a screen
everywhere yeah and so as long as you're
creating something that people are
enjoying on those screens and that can
be widely distributed mm-hmm don't - at
least to me it doesn't really matter
where it goes as long as it does that
yeah I'm waiting for them to start
premiering movies in your home you need
to go to a theater at a certain time
like it's the most it is the most
outrageously antiquated consumption of
anything I know
remember when they were showing the
debates in VR like you could literally
put on your oculus and watch the debates
with a bunch of other people like that's
what movies that's almost impressive
been able to hold on to that format for
so long and I mean that that format
started because it was literally the
only you're like okay we need a real
yeah you got this clunky ass real and
it's on a wagon so we're out to like
Kansas City which was the West and
they're like okay we're gonna put it in
this thing and then we're gonna like put
a fence around ya and anyone who comes
in will charge money to you that's
perfect yeah and it works so well for so
long but now we have the cloud we don't
need it right it's crazy and it's crazy
well I cannot wait to see what you do
next and thank you so much for coming on
and supporting this endeavor corner and
sharing your thoughts and I wish you
nothing but the best and success and
everything you do yeah you guys as well
it's always a pleasure to watch y'all
girl absolutely alright thank you Anna
thank you high five
like comment and subscribe thank you
well that about wraps it up thank you
again to Anna Akana for coming out on
this episode if you guys haven't seen
her stuff definitely go and check it out
it's very good remember we do these
episodes every week so if you're
listening to us remember to download if
you're watching us remember to subscribe
and until next time stay classy